[Music]
this driver's got 480 grades they're
gonna need the window are they gonna use
the smoke nade the window and there
could be two kills coming up here this
could actually be a nightmare here they
come the airstrike tactical huge coming
in both kills landing oh my goodness
this is gonna be a lot of fun wants to
try and hold off the rotation oscar's
gone chris isn't up still in the picture
oh still very much in the realm oh chris
he's found three it's down to it two one
two chris can he close this with an x oh
my god
chris the wolf of wall street gets an
ace and it's championship point mouse
sports anything to work with just gonna
be trying to get one more brag out of it
smoked out bomb down everyone chasing
down gets a trevor the knife comes in
simple of course stabs him straight in
the chest that was maybe the only chance
but guardian comes back in oh god if he
gets two there's still more to go though
that might must pop the ball the peaks
come in the guardian will not stop one
more to go and guardian gets them all
[Applause]
dust 2 without question is the most
iconic counter-strike map of all time
but in counter-strike global offensive
specifically there is not a single map
more important to the fabric of its
competitive legacy than mirage it's the
place where pros and plebs hone their
skills a deathmatch dojo for all those
looking to make a name for themselves
and now oh ac doubles up triples up what
is that
that's criminal
[Music]
hazy's looking unreal down in ct wants
to try and get more done and oh my
it's the hallowed grounds where the
game's greatest moments have taken place
wants to try and hold off the rotations
oscar's gone chris isn't up still in the
picture op still very much in the round
oh chris he's found three it's down to
it two on two chris can he close this
with an ace oh my god chris the wolf of
wall street gets an ace and it's
championship point mo sports it's the
most played map in cs go and it's
becoming a nightmare because of it
get rid of mirage right now i swear to
god i'm dodging i swear to god i'm
dodging then okay i swear to god i'm
dodging my top three worst map is mirage
mirage and mirage at least favorite map
is probably mirage i still have
nightmares from that map but before we
explore why cs go's most prolific map is
losing its favor we need to discuss how
it got so popular in the first place it
started where all great csgo maps first
made their appearances counter-strike
1.6
wow nice connection from kerrigan
picking up the two mid players from
snobby can he get the third player yes
he can
five or two
fourth break from caragan
what are we watching the map was created
by michael bubquez hull a swedish level
designer and quake pro who had a history
of making maps in several different
games but our story starts in 2004 when
michael would unknowingly create one of
the greatest cs maps of all time but
when players first saw mirage they had a
different name and a much different
aesthetic youtuber three clicks phillips
spoke with michael and shed some light
on how the first iteration decpl strike
came to be at that time cpl was the
biggest tournament and maps like cpl
fire and cpl mill were particularly
popular bobcats got in touch with tonya
from cpl and asked if they were
interested in new maps and she said yes
if they're any good so we got to work on
mirage or as it was called back then the
strike later in 2007 decpl strike would
get ported over to counter-strike source
and soon after bobcats went back into
the 1.6 version to make some layout
changes and renamed the map mirage
looking like the love child of dust2 and
inferno mirage would find its way into
the professional map rotation for source
tournaments outside of cpl and just days
into the release of cs go mirage would
get ported over by a user named mad max
valve couldn't ignore the map's insane
popularity so in 2013 they created their
own official version and added it to the
pool that bomb plants already been
happening for quite a while here so hiko
and sean that's a good kill from hika
but they realize dupreeh is still in
there somewhere they're going to try and
go for it here they want to go all in
eco comes in with another kill then back
to a two on two that bomb so far take
they gotta move quick right now they're
going for it the defuse is already
happening hey car you kidding me he's
gonna go for it they win the round he go
fix up a triple a cloud nine win it what
they're a man to the good here vertus
bro but uh that is massive
and then he finished off the job mirage
being added to the competitive map pool
changed csgo forever and in a lot of
different ways another jumping shot
another one and another passer it had an
iron grip on the community everyone was
cueing it back to back both pros and
casuals alike and over the next five
years it will become the most popular
map in the history of cs go there was a
little bit of something for everyone on
mirage and players couldn't get enough
mirage became cs goes de facto
battleground every pro team worth its
soul grinded this map until they knew
every inch and for good reason and it's
still a tec-9 though for snacks as neo
falls which starts to
turn the favor into navies a seized in
in the open nearly gets caught toward
the sandwich's passion he will go down
eventually on the repeat but not before
snacks gets one flamingo you called it
they're on the defuse it's a
championship inside smoke
mirage is a familiar yet very different
map in a lot of ways its sniper nest is
reminiscent of inferno's window room yet
it plays a much larger role in how the
map plays out its catwalk is clearly
inspired by dust twos but it also
provides cross map coverage for
everything it borrows from other maps it
adds entirely new unique angles and
boosts that have allowed for incredible
creativity my favorite map currently
would have to be
mirage i think i think it's very
uh evenly sided it's not very
like maps like nuke or train where it's
very heated city sideways whereas
i feel like you can do a lot of things
on both sides so uh it's very fun to
play mirage is also just one of those
special maps that are easy to learn but
hard to master it has extremely long
angles and fast rotate paths that are
built for more puggy play styles
seemingly a three on two a five on two
right every single time still winnable
fallen needs the ace clutch he's got two
oh come on falling yeah the blood's
flowing now
oh
it gets sick
and my goodness but over the years it
has also proved to be an amazing
training ground for developing and
practicing the basics of sight execute
smoke lineups and map control heroic
throw fast right side a smokes from
spawn and flashes over ramp heroic
brushes out ramp and preemptively smoke
ram to extinguish rpk's molly rpk gets
blind and boreup gets the kill onto him
heroic takes sight in plant default
every cs player who's stepped foot in a
ranked match has mirage mid-smoke
somewhere in their search history
recently it's been actually one of our
stronger maps so i also feel like i have
a good like style for calling on it like
the map makes sense to me and when i
watch like demos i feel like i can grasp
concepts very easily by 2015 mirage was
already skyrocketing in popularity at
pro events and for the next three years
mirage would stand alone as the most
played map on land round number two a
chance for
defensive now to farm some serious cash
it's gonna be kenny to get the first
kill makes it a double looking for his
third he gets four in fact there's the
ace during that period a lot of
tournaments felt like they were decided
by who had the best mirage and the most
dominant teams during that era fought to
be its kings and he might get a free one
oh my goodness he's
london is not looking this is so
horrendous he's looking for the next
player now and get information on where
the next player is this is fantastic
here from pasha he can even keep moving
and there it is he can spot the next
player oh my god faster
how did how did they not oh it's just
unbelievable what do you say to that
joke around dennis is spamming up
through the bench leaving coldzera in a
one-on-four there's the first
looking for a second he connects it oh
and he gets a third as well surely he's
not going to pull this one off oh
caldera the man the missed the beast and
look at this more mind games coming in
the straw that's got four hd grenades
are gonna need the window are they gonna
use a smoke nade the window and there
could be two kills coming up here this
could actually be a nightmare here they
come the airstrike tactical huge coming
in both kills landing oh my goodness
this is gonna be a lot of fun however
things started to change when cs go went
into its online era in march of 2020.
mirage was still one of the most played
maps on lan but its frequency started to
drop and its favor among the community
took a hit i think mirage is definitely
a tiring map i feel like it's become the
new dusty you know it's more puggy
there's nothing that really is new to
the map and it's pretty much the same
thing over and over and yeah there's not
much new to it i think it should
definitely be replaced but
you know i'm not the one to say that
yeah i don't know that dynamic is
interesting like picking between mirage
and
like keeping another map in i do think
it gets a little played out um they
added the window boosting and that
helped a little bit but you know a lot
of it's to the same effect mirage was
being played to death the things that
made it famous the executes the puggy
aim battles were now making it
nauseating
and that feeling of fatigue made its way
into ranked matchmaking to this day it
is still the most played map but the
strain is clearly being felt
but these complaints aren't anything new
pros have been complaining about maps
being boring and predictable for years
vertigo is an a-ramp simulator cash was
too puggy dust 2 is a dinosaur we've
heard it all before so how do you fix a
map that's only legitimate problem is
that it's played too much well if we use
dust 2 as a case study the answer would
be to do nothing you see dust 2 has its
issues but the most glaring one is mid
doors they just sucked and the question
of how to fix it has been a hot one
within the community for years can they
actually get a kill initially yes they
can come on guys come on
val finally made the decision to fix the
problem by forcing t side to jump into
suicide if they wanted to peak mid at
the start of the round the change was
received with mixed opinions some loved
it but others thought it just created
new problems and others still argue that
changing such an iconic map even the
slightest would be a sin in and of
itself mirage yeah it does kind of feel
like that's too old-school like i don't
really know like you know they've
changed a site over the years multiple
times maybe you could do that again it
is weird though when you do that because
like once you've seen so many legendary
moments happen it is a little weird but
people adapt normally within the year
and ever since the change to dust too
its number of professional appearances
have dwindled who's to say that won't
happen to mirage if valve decides to do
something crazy to its layout you see
more than any other map mirage is the
epitome of don't fix what ain't broken
and it could be that all we need is a
break from it
it's just played out that's all men like
them that's fine honestly it's just it's
played out csgo is still one of the most
popular fbs games out there despite
having broken code and maps older than
its player base but it would be nice to
see some brand new maps enter the active
duty pool more frequently on the other
hand if you take away the map or change
it in any significant way you run the
risk of losing the map that built so
many memories it doesn't really have
anything to work with just going to be
trying to get one more frag out of it
smoked out bomb down everyone chasing
down gets a tremor the knife comes in
simple of course stabs him straight in
the chest and takes him down
he's watching the cross to short that's
information they know and say oh niko
that was maybe the only chance but
guardian comes back in oh god if he gets
two there's still more to go though that
i must pop the ball the peaks come in
the guardian will not stop one more to
go and guardian gets them all this is
looking like such a huge issue
mousesports had everything going in
their way but just the timings started
to swing towards vitality frozen doing
what he can five seconds to go he's
gonna get the bomb down it's gonna get
the bomb oh
what the hell is that from frozen that
doesn't make any sense an electronic
looking for the cleanest finish she's
been turned on
no health really but he's still hitting
shots he's already got three and four
and five and oh my god
despite the map being stale and
overplayed players are still finding new
ways to be creative pushing the
boundaries on not only how we play
mirage but all of cs oh quick boost to
get up there that's a that's a cool
trick to be able to do they get shut
down there's a lot of people on the
other side i kind of wonder james did he
he must have realized there are more
people there he's running with his back
turns did he just stole it off he just
took the op away from them
he he grabbed the he actually went on a
retrieval mission
grabs the op and just says no this is
mine now oh my goodness james
this man is just insulting them in their
faces even to this day the map provides
us with game defining moments
gets the info he just has to hit this
shot and he's done it for heroic
the leader
calling well above his ears clearing
corners
in a lot of ways mirage is the perfect
map and if matters and team comps
continue to change who knows what crazy
things we'll see in the future jason
they've built a giant stack of people on
top of the ticket booth tickets please
tickets please no ticket
shout out to indiana jones
well this is going to be a surprise
one of the stupidest things i've seen in
a long time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick tock
you